hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll and
it may be perfectly clear or maybe I
should mention that I'm a city guy by
Nature I didn't grow up in a city I grew
up in the suburbs typical American
Suburban upbringing but as soon as I got
to move to cities I realized that that's
where I really belonged I've gotten to
live in some great cities here in the
United States Boston Chicago Los Angeles
now in Baltimore and believe it or not
We've Ended up talking about cities
quite a bit here on the podcast this was
never you know one of my intentions
starting out but turns out there's an
enormous amount of interesting things to
think about these marvelously complex
human environments we talked with
Catherine Brinkley about the science of
cities uh why they take the shapes they
do in the particular ways and how to use
that to make it better very early on in
the podcast we talked to Jeffrey West
about the relationship between scale
including density in cities and other
things that matter like innovation and
creativity which are concentrated in
city-like environments we talked to will
Wilkinson about cities and politics
there's a strong polarization between
the density of the environment you live
in and where you land on a political
spectrum and we also talked to Joe
Walston about cities and the environment
how urbanization which you might think
is sort of counter to environmental
sustainability is actually the best way
to create environmental sustainability
because it frees up so much land for
other uses so that brings us to today
where we'll be talking to Johanna
Hoffman who is an urban designer and
planner and thinker so she's going to
talk about how we can think about what
cities should be and how best to do that
thinking so in fact a lot of the
conversation we're going to have is not
specifically about this or that Urban
policy although that that gets there but
more or less a methodology that we can
use to think about this which in true
mindscape fashion is this wonderfully
introduce disciplinary idea of
speculative Futures that's also the
title of johanna's new book speculative
Futures design approaches to navigate
change Foster resilience and co-create
the cities we need the idea being that
if you really want to be a good urban
planner the mindset you should be in is
that of a science fiction writer really
someone who thinks about the future
visualizes different possibilities and
then does systems thinking attaching
different implications to different
things that might change in the future
the thing about cities is they're
incredibly interconnected one thing
matters to another Transportation
economy food pollution population a
million different things safety politics
so it all matters in a way that is hard
to wrap a single Grand unified theory
around and instead it can often help to
be a little bit playful be a little bit
speculative think about how everything
interconnects with everything else in a
narrative way rather than a strictly top
own way so I like the conversation
because it ranges over all these
different kind of avenues and ideas and
it matters urbanization is happening
more and more people not just by
absolute numbers but by percentages are
living in cities today and will be in
the future so something to think about
let's go
[Music]
Joanna Hoffman welcome to the landscape
podcast thank you so much a pleasure to
be here
you know we're talking about cities
which we've talked about before in the
podcast and design in the future and
speculation but let me start I have a
softball question and then I have a
tricky question the softball question is
why the focus on cities what's so great
or important about cities
so cities are where a lot of us live not
everybody by any means on the entire
planet but increasingly and I'm sure
this comes as no surprise to the people
who are listening to this podcast more
and more of us are moving to cities when
we're looking at a lot of the problems
that we're currently facing and that
will likely increase in coming years
climatic impacts political instability
we're looking at a lot of unfortunately
this is a devastating truth forced
migration people are going to be moving
unvoluntarily but out of necessity where
are they going to land likely they're
going to land in cities so increasingly
more and more of us live in cities and
moving forward the size of the amount
the amount of our population that we'll
be living in cities will likely increase
so really investigating cities how we
can make them more resilient the systems
that are required in order to sustain
them in more Equitable ways is really a
way of asking how can we as a human
species become more resilient more
equipped to handle the change changes
that are headed our way
it's really remarkable the extent to
which urbanization is happening like I
said I've done a couple podcasts on this
and uh just the it's a sweeping change
that we almost take for granted because
so many of us do live in cities it seems
natural to us but it hasn't been like
this for very long no it's all
relatively recent and I think that's
also part of why the scales the Scopes
the speeds of change that we are
experiencing even in just this
generation even in just the last 30
years is
amazing and quite frightening and also
exciting compared to the trajectories
and the speeds of change that we have
experienced in the past so when we're
talking about degrees of uncertainty
that our systems have to negotiate that
our governance approaches need to be
able to handle their increasing quite
rapidly and so what are the ways that we
can start to collaboratively Envision
what we might want to do to engage work
with that uncertainty becomes a much
more important question
well that leads perfectly into my
slightly trickier question which is when
we think about cities historically and
maybe moving into the future how much of
their shape and function and so forth is
intentional and planned versus how much
of it is just sort of spontaneously
self-organizing due to the desires of
all these different agents trying to do
their best yeah it's a great question
and the history of cities is a massive
one and so my particular expertise is in
designing systems strategies
interventions for a relatively present
moment and also in the coming future so
I'll just put a disclaimer out there
that many people are much more highly
qualified to look at the long-term
history of cities than I am that said
when we look at the range of ways that
cities have developed over time you know
it's a combination right there's not one
extreme or the other and it very much
depends on which particular region we're
looking at and what time frame we're
investigating a new archaeological
evidence is coming up all the time to
challenge pre-existing understanding of
what some of those patterns were like
but I would say that's often a
combination of the two in many different
cities there was some aspect of
centralization again huge massive area
for research and archaeological findings
are changing this quite rapidly if
people have not read the dawn of
everything by grayburn I feel that his
co-writer was Weber amazing findings on
just this topic so so again lots of
other areas that people should
investigate for more details but what
people are finding is again a
combination of both a centralized plan
of some kind and then also iteration and
kind of Grassroots response to those
plans as people feel into explore remix
spaces in order to respond to their
actual needs and we see that in
different moments throughout history I'm
thinking a little bit more recently in
the 21st or the 20th century like
corbusia are very you know famous
architect responsible for a lot of the
modernist design that we still see in
many different building efforts today
and he had a lot of different projects
in different parts of the world and
there's some amazing examples
photographic documentation about the way
that he would design a space and how it
would look when it was first constructed
and then how people who actually live
there would change it whether bye for
drying laundry or you know changing door
frames or Shifting the orientation of
Windows sometimes we change spaces in
order to make them work for what we want
and we do that at different scales
according to the amount of organization
that we often have within our own
families or in our wider communities
what for you are the great success
stories of urban planning I mean I guess
urban planning might not be the right
phrase because maybe it's too specific
but I think that there have been some
semi-notable disasters or at least
things have gone terribly wrong because
people try to over plan but maybe we're
not hearing the stories of good things
maybe you know I don't know Central Park
or some other feature of the city that
you really needed to sit down and
protect via uh intentional planning
rather than just let it happen that way
again great question and what comes to
mind immediately since you referenced
Central Park is both the good sides of
it and also the negative sides of it
that was an effort in large part to Spur
development on the island of Manhattan
because at the time that it was planned
in the mid-19th century
there was really not a lot of
development that was in the farther
north section of the island and so it
was an opportunity really to create a
space that around it would invite more
development to occur so it was really a
specular practice I was about raising
land values in the area and about
spurring more construction and as I'm
sure people have you know heard of their
interested in Central Park there were
communities who were living in that area
in that land some of whom were
communities of color that were displaced
in the process so when we look at
Manhattan today it is really valuable to
have Central Park there so helpful to
have an open Green vegetated Space that
invites us to go outside there's a lot
of cooling impacts that it has from an
infrastructural level when we look at
our parks in general massively important
in terms of absorbing rainfall in terms
of regulating microclimate so valuable
to have those spaces and I think it's
important when we look at anything that
is centralized in the way that it is
planned and then developed what the
negative impacts can be and in Central
Park yes people were displaced their
homes were taken away in those
communities were fractured as a result
so positive impact
essential to identify and it's also a
critical thing to ask at what cost
and other examples besides Central Park
that you keep in mind as paradigms of
design gone right
you know since we're on the subject of
Frederick La instead
um the emeralds Park system that he
created in Boston I think was quite
thoughtful again it was about green
infrastructure so green infrastructure
being basically the ways that we can
work with natural systems in order to
yes regulate microclimate provide spaces
for people to gather with each other and
also manage leading capacity as well
this is a slightly more complicated
example but it's also a much more
older ancient practice of working with
landscape so when you look at Mexico
City before conquistadors got there it
was tanoctic land and they had this
really amazing system of chinambas which
is kind of building up low-lying watery
areas into agricultural systems before
conquistadors got there they were also
quite larger islands for different kinds
of housing developments or kind of
centralized Gathering religious spaces
and now when you go to Mexico City it's
not as if the chinampas are doing great
it's quite a complicated area of the
region and yet they still are used for
pretty robust Agricultural Development
so again it's not I think like perfect
development it's gone amazing but this
way of working with a much older form of
navigating working with our landscape is
still present today and there are some
farmers who are out there who have
generational
experience and really strong added
wisdom for how to manage those spaces
could they have more support in moving
that forward absolutely could there be
better regulations and how a lot of
Wastewater from surrounding areas is
flowing into those chainampas 100 and
does that negate the value of that
particular practice which again has been
around for a really long time I don't
think so I think it's worth
investigating slightly more technocratic
um organized means of intervention as
well as looking at some of these much
older practices that humans have been
doing for hundreds and sometimes
thousands of years
there's a great Point beneath everything
you just said which is that when you
think about cities and designing them
you generally don't have a blank slate
right there's something going on already
it reminds me a little bit I don't know
if this is a good analogy or not but I
did an end of the year podcast where I
talked about thinking carefully and
slowly and how this was against in some
ways the Silicon Valley ethos which is
getting Elon Musk in trouble right now
because of Twitter and uh a legacy
Software System is a little bit like a
city right it's been built up over time
it's complex some things work and we
don't know why and are there dangers in
the whole field that you're in of saying
well we can do better than this without
realizing how many contingencies there
were yes I think that's a really useful
analogy because and I'm not an engineer
a software engineer a coding expert but
it's also my understanding that you know
when it comes to certain satellites that
we have put out into space some of them
are quite old now and so they're using
coding language that is not what people
use now and it's from the people I know
who are much more involved in this world
than I am they've told me that that
coding language that people used to use
back in the 70s the 80s was a lot more
precise and spare because there just
wasn't as much storage space in the
memory cards that were used to manage
those satellites and so when it comes to
trying to improve or respond or repair
something that's gone wrong a lot of
people today don't have that coding
skill in order to work with this
technology that we still ideally would
be able to use and rely upon rather than
take something down or let it become
space junk or put like spend the money
to build something new so yes what we're
working with is not a blank slate if we
can be more facile in the way that we're
able to operate and use systems from
different time frames we stand a chance
to really be able to harness our
resources in a much more effective way
and cities in some ways are quite
similar in that you know in the field
people in the architecture engineering
and Construction Industries I often call
cities you know a green field or a
Brownfield a Brownfield is often a space
that already has development there and a
green shield is used to describe what is
a blank flight essentially and yet
arguably just like you said no place is
a blank Fleet even if there's no
pre-existing structures or
infrastructure on it because there's
still water flows that are happening
there are still different kinds of soil
capacities for absorbing water there
there's different kinds of systems that
are already in place and so pretending
as if those systems don't exist can
sometimes be okay if you build there for
a certain period of time but usually
eventually there will be issues that
occur whether it's flooding whether it's
extreme heat or drought we live in
Landscapes that are Dynamic and so
pretending as if we don't need to take
that Dynamic quality into account when
we build is setting SF for really
problematic context whether it's in the
near term or the slightly longer term so
when I think of how we work with what is
pre-existing in cities it's both within
a cultural context who is there
infrastructural what is there and also
the larger context of how does this
operate and respond to the Dynamics of
the region in which we're situated
okay so let's imagine that let me put it
this way let's put the audience in the
mindset of someone who's trying to think
about how we should influence not even
plan but you know think about
possibilities for the future city what
are the goals like what what are the
primary things that you keep in mind
when you try to imagine what would be a
good working future city
I think about it in terms of identifying
what are the potential impacts of a
particular intervention so a good city
in my mind is one where those who live
within it have a certain facility with
basically systems thinking if we're
going to put in a new Transit Corridor
for example what will that Transit
Corridor do in terms of its impacts on
Mobility for sure how people are able to
move around that given space but what
will that do in terms of you know family
Dynamics if we're able to move more
quickly efficiently through the places
that we live does that mean that we
maybe get to spend more time with loved
ones how does that change maybe
Educational Systems because if you spend
more time you know if you if you're a
parent and you have kids and you're
spending more time with them maybe you
can help them if they have difficulties
in homework maybe that lessens the
burden on Public School Systems so again
looking at our interventions within a
systemic framework of both
infrastructural moods but then how those
infrastructural moves might then impact
cultural norms how they might have an
economic impact as well these things are
operating within an interconnected
system how can we become more factsal in
exploring what those interconnected
impacts are so that we can make
decisions that will hopefully take us in
a you know preferable trajectory and I
think that's where speculative Futures
tools can be quite helpful because
systems thinking is hard right it's not
the easiest thing to do not all of us
are really primed to think that way and
even when we are identifying causal
Pathways one thing that definitely
causes another is nearly impossible it's
quite difficult and you can usually only
identify that with certainty long after
the fact so in order to explore still
what is systemic context and the suite
of impacts could be from a potential
intervention that somebody is proposing
we have to do our best and one of the
ways that we can communicate that quite
effectively with others is through
narratives through Visual storytelling
through experiences that can hopefully
render that systemic context
in a way that people can respond to
I guess one of the issues is that
different people who might ultimately
live in the city want different things
from it you know if you're like me and
you want to move to a city which I just
did six months ago where did you move
from Los Angeles to Baltimore why and
what you're thinking of is like where
are the restaurants where the music
venues uh someone else might be thinking
of what are the schools like what is the
transportation like someone else might
be what about my customer base you know
can they afford it do I have the right
people in the audience and and you have
to keep everybody happy that I guess I'm
just repeating the point you made about
systems thinking being very hard yeah
totally finding a world where all of our
different preferred worlds can fit is
challenging and this is not to say that
by using speculative Futures tools we're
gonna like come up with the best way to
do that but I think that when we're a
lot clearer as individuals as families
as communities we can be a lot more
specific in the ways that we can
advocate for those needs and also debate
how another group's needs might conflict
with our own so basically it's not as if
having Civic debate is something that
we're great at in the society at this
present moment just having space to
disagree with each other in a thoughtful
respectful way we're not at a great
moment with that sadly that said very
sadly when we look at the possibility
space that potential Futures can present
to us I think they're a way of casing
some of the disagreements and challenges
that we have in terms of really
different needs that different
communities have is to acknowledge the
fact that the challenges that we
currently face won't necessarily last
forever it's not to ignore them or
pretend that they don't exist it's just
that 20 years from now things could very
well be different they're definitely
different than they were in the year
2003 so how to allow ourselves to use
that possibility space as a way to
temporarily say okay it's not great
right now but what would we prefer let's
just give ourselves that moment as
individuals and then if we could have a
very specific detailed idea based on
Research hopefully on a systemic context
if I can advocate for what I might
prefer and you can advocate for what you
might prefer can we see where they may
be intersect are there commonalities
that are hopefully not so much informed
by you know my potential mistrust of
your perspective or your confusion about
where I'm coming from if we can use this
possibility space get as detailed as
possible and hopefully use communication
tools that you can respond to and me
vice versa from you which again a
storytelling narrative space can be
quite helpful in doing that
I think there's a chance for us to find
hopefully a space for dialogue that is
slightly less fraught than what we often
deal with in the present moment and then
work back to today to identify steps to
reach helpfully a more
commonly held vision of where we want to
go well the the emphasis on speculative
Futures is a good one and I I did want
to let's take a step back because you're
you're talking about the impact of it
and and how it can be helpful I want to
give you a chance to tell us what it is
what you have a a way of thinking about
designing the future of cities it's
right there in the title of your book
and then right there in the beginning of
your book you say wait a minute aren't
all Futures speculative we don't know
which one is there so what what exactly
do you have in mind when you mean this
particular methodology
so speculative Futures are a suite of
design tools for creating high
resolution visions of potential
realities like you say and this is in
the author's note of my book all visions
of the future are inherently speculative
so that phrase is redundant that said
because the ways that many of us
Envision the future and this is just a
basic human tendency is to use our
understandings at the present moment in
the past to kind of extend and do some
guesswork into what we think the future
might become so becoming more
basically having the capacity to
challenge the status quo in terms of
what we think the future could be is
something that often has to be built we
need help in doing that we need a
certain kind of visual framework we need
support from people who help us
challenge the ways that we've been
trained to see the world in order to
expand our ideas of what might actually
be able to occur in the future because
when we're talking about the challenges
that we Face there are many climate
changes freaky we have you know
political division in this country that
feels like it will never disappear we
have racial inequality that's been going
on since I'm very well like all of these
problems are very entrenched and so for
many of us when we think about the
future it's really hard again to imagine
a reality where those conditions do not
just persist that the status quo doesn't
just continue so speculative futures
can be a helpful way especially when
they're facilitated by people who are
particularly skilled in this practice of
inviting us to imagine beyond what is
they can be a way of helping us
challenge that status quo thinking and
using that possibility space that I
mentioned previously as an area to test
out alternative trajectories again not
with any sort of guarantee that they
will definitely come true but at least
to give us the chance to explore what
they might be and see how if they're
preferable to me hopefully to you to
other people if we might work towards
identifying ways of getting there so
these tools come in different forms
science fiction is definitely one
whether it's in written form or it's in
film or video
um world building when people are
familiar with fantasy fiction that's
often where you think of it Lord of the
Rings is definitely built on World
building it's taking a more cohesive
vision of what a potential reality might
be and really abiding by a set of rules
in order to make that reality become
real yeah what are the economic systems
of a particular area what are the
geopolitical concerns really getting
very detailed from a kind of world view
um design fictions are a kind of
speculative future which is really a way
of developing objects that you might
need in order to exist in a potential
future reality so it's a way of
basically incorporating different sorts
of Senses in order to fill in to what
the future might be for some people
writing a science fiction story it's
totally what they need in order to get
into the details of a potential future
for others we want to use our touch we
might want to incorporate a sense of
smell and so really honoring the
different ways that people explore
information and relate to potential
trajectories of change is a big part of
what speculative features can offer us
there are ways of broadening how we
start to talk about some of these very
complex issues and how we invite others
to experience debate explore them with
us when you're talking about science
fiction stories are you talking about
literally the stories that have been
written or are you talking about a way
that Urban thinkers and designers like
yourself can create new fictional
scenarios for your own purposes the
reason why I ask is because when science
fiction writers as someone who has
consulted on Hollywood movies where
there's sort of science fictiony fantasy
elements they don't care about it making
sense they have a story to tell and that
they want to bring in different elements
when they move the story in the
direction they want it to move in other
words they might not be doing systems
thinking they might not be thinking
through all of the implications of all
the uh you know there's all sorts of
stories where time travel appears and
then disappears later on in in the story
right so are you relying or taking
inspiration from existing science
fictional narratives or are you sort of
encouraging designers to think like
authors
before I answer that specific question I
just want to say that science fiction
comes in many different forms of the
ways that people are trying to translate
Research into a narrative form and I
don't think that all of them are created
equal by any means that said I think
good science fiction writers are quite
good researchers and I think they do
take the science quite seriously that
they try and explore the ramifications
of in their narratives you know she
obviously was very positive about his
own work but Isaac asimov's you know
talked about himself as being a
scientist and a researcher first in a
science fiction author second so I just
want to preface this by saying that and
I know that this is true for some people
who are you know writers and production
designers in Hollywood some of them take
the science quite seriously they might
not be trained as scientist but they
want to try and get it right because in
order to tell a good story and I'm for
sure biased but I think that this is
true the great films that we see the
great science fiction stories that we
see are quite based in truth and then
the story The Narrative part is just a
departure from where the facts start to
end because if you go a certain
trajectory into the future there's going
to be a point at which science can no
longer follow
so when I think about the ways that
science fiction can be helpful in how we
design cities about how we think about
potential trajectories of the future I'm
definitely thinking about the shared
narratives that we already have which is
often influenced by the science fiction
films books Etc that are out there
already when we think about you know
dystopian introductories of change a lot
of us do think about Blade Runner came
out in the 80s hugely influential just
both like a great film and also captured
our imagination to I think the point
where it's created some really
devastating impacts certain cities you
know developing areas in Asia for
example different developers have wanted
to translate the Blade Runner aesthetic
into built physical form so when we're
talking about the ways that science
fiction already influences our ideas
about cities about what we want to see
it's massive so when I think about
articulating different trajectories of
change and exploring preferred Futures
speculative Futures tools can be ways
for us to kind of take responsibility
for the imaginaries that already affect
our thinking and be a lot more specific
about how we do or don't actually want
to enact them and to explore
Alternatives so when we look at City
making in general today
a lot of planners Architects designers
often use the word and this is also used
in strategic planning and and Military
strategy the word scenarios
scenarios right is just another word for
a potential future what is the scenario
if we're talking about 10 years in the
future there could be many but if we're
going to dive into and explore specifics
we're going to pick one and then get
into the details there
scenarios were coined the phrase by
people over at Rand the think tank based
in Santa Monica and other parts of the
world
military supported and they developed
scenarios in part to explore basically
the ramifications of nuclear Armageddon
in the Cold War one person in particular
a guy named Hermann Khan many people
probably heard of him pretty famous
he was a science fiction geek when he
was growing up he loved to read sci-fi
and so when he got to random they were
trying to understand ways of responding
proactively to some of the tensions in
the Cold War he wanted to basically use
sci-fi as a way of exploring you know
these potential trajectories have
changed to really to coin or to use his
phrase to think about the unthinkable
nuclear Armageddon is frightening how do
we think about it we can think about it
in terms of playing out a story doing a
war game which is basically another kind
of sci-fi
so rather than say science fiction
because the people who are funding those
projects science fiction doesn't sound
serious how can we come up with a
different word we could call it
scenarios so this is to say that science
fiction has already been used for very
serious strategic thinking for a long
time now there's a long history of that
and so when we're talking about how
designers Architects planners
strategists already designed cities they
use scenarios which means that they use
sci-fi they might not do it in as
detailed or you know narratively
cohesive ways that very good writers do
but they're still using the basic tenets
of exploring what the research tells
about this potential trajectory of
change and trying to understand what
that means for daily life for military
operations for you know agricultural
systems
one of the little Consulting gigs that I
had was uh with Ridley Scott and it was
fun what project was that for it was for
one that never got made uh he was going
to adapt Joe holderman's the Forever War
but he did the Martian instead so I
can't complain the Martian was really
really good but it was hilarious to meet
him because he had no interest in
hearing the scientists he just wanted to
tell stories himself the entire time
that's what he does for a living and
someone mentioned how more cities are
beginning to look like Blade Runner and
he goes yes and do I earn a penny off of
that no
there's some intense legality stuff
going on there but of course it is not
meant it was not meant as a template for
future cities I mean I wonder how much
of it was prediction and how much of it
was inspiration I mean were were they
just foreseeing and not just released
God obviously Sid Mead and others you
know working on the the look and feel of
that film where they seeing themselves
what was going to inevitably happen to
the future of cities or was it that the
movie came out and people said yes let's
make cities look like that it's a great
question and I would love to hear Ridley
Scott's specific thought process on that
my take on it you know they made blade
runner in the 80s on the tail end of a
lot of clean modernist focused emphasis
on cities being you know very highly
organized and wide boulevards and
everything should be clean and green and
Blade Runner was the antithesis of that
right they did a lot of research on
different mostly Asian cities they spent
a lot of time in Taiwan for example they
spend other time in Japan and they were
looking for the not modernist version
City in order to influence what became
that really influential production
design that Sydney created and so it was
really I think about looking at the city
as dangerous as dark obviously looking
at the impacts of new technologies and
what it means to relate to non-human
intelligent systems and taking a very
dystopian look at what that is and so I
think it both isn't example of how our
tendency towards using dystopia as a
means of warning about potential
negative structures which is very useful
that's an important thing I think that
we as a species do we see something that
it's confusing or new potentially
frightening let's look at what the
potential negative impacts could be if
it plays out over time what I think has
happened with Blade Runner and many
other dystopian focused narratives is
that when that is the majority of the
narratives that we have out there it
shapes our Collective thinking to kind
of assume that dystopia is the only way
forward our Collective imaginations
about what is possible again form a kind
of underlying assumption that if we
don't challenge them or really inquire
why we have that assumption to begin
with
it can shape so much of our thinking
definitely in the present and for sure
about where we see our futures taking us
there's ideas about who we are they're
so important for shaping the questions
that we ask and how we answer them
you've made the point but I'll give you
a chance to sort of amplify it uh on how
conventional ways of thinking about
cities to bring it back to cities tend
to I guess get stuck in ruts they tend
to sort of reinforce the status quo and
and one of the things one of the roles I
guess of the speculative Futures idea
would be to get us out of that rut to
think in new ways is that fair yeah it's
definitely and it makes me think of a
conversation that you had with one of
your guests in a previous week I can't
remember who but basically our capacity
to imagine into the future being a
fundamental aspect of what it means to
be human and I am not an expert like
your previous guest was on on human and
animal behavior but what I do know is
that the part of our brain that is
responsible for imagining potential
trajectories of change is quite close to
the area of our brain that stores our
memory and so the memories that we have
both of our own personal lives and also
our understanding of why you know our
cities are the way they are the way our
societies are the way that they are the
way that Humanity has operated over time
we use those memories to remix
our ideas and inform about how potential
future trajectories could occur we can't
imagine in many ways what we have not
experienced and so speculative futures
and I'm really just you know recycling
many different amazing pieces of
information that other futurists I think
you'd Steward candy for example
um have already stated is that
speculative Futures are ways to explore
and then experience potential Futures in
ways that give us new memories so that
we can remix more memories that again
are not conditioned on status quo
thinking to articulate
what we might prefer for our features I
mean I think I'm on board with the
program as general in general
um but nevertheless to mention you know
we human beings have imaginations
they're crucial to us it it does get
tricky sometimes to even use our
imaginations to go beyond our everyday
experience someone once pointed out that
even in science fiction usually the
scenario we're looking at is based on
one or two big ideas and all of their
implications right space travel or the
Matrix or synthetic biology and Gene
editing but rarely do you get all of
them in the same book or or scenario
that would be or it'll be so different
than how we live right now that it'll be
hard to relate to it uh so how do we how
do we spur our imaginations to be more
comprehensive that way rather than just
sort of thinking one big idea and
spinning out his implications yeah again
I think it's a system of thinking stuff
and you know it's again not easy to do
but there are certain way is that we can
both support our own capacity for system
thinking and also look to other people
who do a good job of exploring in a very
systemic way but potential trajectories
of change are and
do our best to absorb that information
I'm sure everyone's heard of the
ministry of the future that's definitely
taking a systemic view of a potential
trajectory of change very detailed and
it's not looking at Jets you know a
technological intervention or what
happens you know when nuclear war occurs
it's trying to say hey this is a
trajectory you know Kim Stanley Robinson
is looking specifically at climate
change
and what happens from a Global
Perspective when the current
trajectories that we are facing start to
unfold but he asked I think the very
valuable question of not just what does
a potential positive response look like
but what are the challenges involved in
any sort of positive response so he
takes he calls it uptopia basically it's
not about articulating or exploring
Utopia it's about Utopia as a process
that there is no destination that is
ideal that it's really about if we're
trying to give ourselves the thought
exercise let alone you know come up with
a strategic plan let's just like think
about it
doing it from a systemic perspective
essential and looking at the challenges
that are inherent that you know if you
for example come up with a trajectory of
change it's not necessarily going to be
great for me so let's play that out if
it's not great for me what might I do in
response and what might I try and
cultivate in terms of conversations with
my colleagues my support system in order
to challenge you back but like if we're
moving towards a positive trajectory and
we have this challenge between us now
what might happen over time that's not
entirely negative
so again Kim Stanley Robinson not all of
us are writers like he is we don't have
to be but what we can do is both look
towards different uptopian another word
for it is protopian not dystopian or
Utopia just looking at like a potential
positive trajectory that incorporates
all of the difficulties all of the
challenges all of the Nuance which again
is a systems level perspective
how can we look for more of those and
then also demand more of those from the
people who make media that we consume
and that right stories that we're trying
to understand that look in news analysis
that we you know look at on a daily
regular basis I think more and more in
especially the media landscape people
are calling for Less dystopian focused
narratives of potential trajectories of
change and that said people still love
watching dystopian stuff so how can more
of us request demand that really Scott
do not just make another dystopian thing
I want to see your take because he is a
great Storyteller even if he doesn't
take the science incredibly seriously so
the next time that you consult for him I
hope that you can Advocate he's a very
visual person right that's that's part
of what makes different directors very
different like he knew exactly how
certain scenes were going to look long
before there was a script for those
scenes like the words were less
important but one of the like approaches
to that just as a counterweight because
like you say every director is different
I worked with with Alex McDowell who's a
production designer he also runs the
world building Institute at USC he also
has a consulting company really talented
person on so many levels he's a
production designer and the film that he
is the most famous for is Minority
Report and it was really fascinating to
get to work with him on his World
building process which it kind of
started to develop for that film and one
of the things that was really powerful
that he shared about what that process
was like Steven Spielberg hired him Alex
McDowell the production designer along
with the writer at the same time so that
they developed the story of the film in
conjunction with how that world was
built so it happened at the same time
that McDowell was basically doing a lot
of interviews with different scientific
experts to understand the research that
might inform they made Minority Report
around 2000 and it was set in a kind of
20 50-ish time frame so whenever you're
looking at 50 years from now it's all
science fiction
so he did his best to gather experts
together do these research initiatives
and synthesize very different
perspectives
into a world and then understand what
that world would translate into in terms
of the story so that's to say that there
are many different ways of telling
stories there are many different tools
for how those stories are constructed so
it's not to say that all science fiction
is made equal it's not to say that all
films are made equated or not so how can
more of us I think become facile with
these tools many of which are adopted in
these kinds of media that most of us are
influenced by in some capacity to be
more Discerning to be more thoughtful
about what we absorb the ideas about the
future that we inherently start to
ingest and then be critical about the
ones that we're using in order to inform
our ideas about where we might want to
go I like the emphasis on collaboration
in the example of Minority Report there
while reading your book I couldn't help
but think of the podcast they did with
Jane McGonagall who does uh gaming
scenarios right and one of the ideas
it's it's really very simple in
retrospect but no one person has an
infinite imagination and there will be
things that other people think of that
they didn't so rather than having one
person whose Vision takes over
everything let it play out with
different people responding in their own
individual ways and you'll discover
things that no one person would have
thought of 100 yeah Jay McGonagall is
fantastic for lots of reasons and I
think that particular emphasis of hers
is a very powerful one and it's one that
I'm particularly interested in both in
my research and also in my professional
work what are tools processes where we
can harness and develop our capacities
for collected imagination because yeah
not one person has all the answers and
even if they think they did they're
going to if we adopt just that one
single perspective of a very narrow
perspective they're going to enact
impacts that are going to not be
advantageous to all people or all
non-human systems so let's be as
thorough as we can about exploring the
different perspectives that need to
influence the different interventions
that we make so that we ideally aren't
going to enact more adverse impacts over
time
we're seeing more and more that we are
in you know an interconnected Planet
let's be real about testing out the
interconnections of the
the projects that impacts the
interventions that we are proposing so
that we don't create a bigger mess for
ourselves than we already have I think
this is a massive statement but on a
general level I think that it's true a
lot of the challenges that we are facing
today are the result of very narrow
limited thinking and a perspective that
what is done in one place will not
affect what happens in another place
that's not true so how do we
come up with a way of both exploring and
articulating new potential positive
interventions but also collaborating on
the actual impacts that those
interventions might have and I think the
narrative storytelling space is a
powerful one I think games are a kind of
story so you know sometimes we want to
have stories that are interactive in
real time I think LARPing live action
and role play is something that for a
long time was really passed off as
something that you know people who love
Dungeons and Dragons do like for big
nerds and Geeks what people are finding
in Jama gobble McGonagall is great at
advocating for this is that they're also
really amazing ways of exploring very
sophisticated Concepts whether
Healthcare technology or obviously
military strategy or ways of you know
healing from emotional trauma games are
massively influential in how we
communicate with ourselves and other
people and so when it comes to different
speculative Futures tactics some of them
are experiential and incorporate a lot
of role play some of them are slightly
more narrative and they encourage a
little bit more internal reflection and
kind of individual storytelling that
then there are opportunities to share
with others so it's just a way I think
of understanding that there are many
different ways of collaborating with
each other
and exploring the suite of tool sets
that can help us do so so that given a
particular scenario
a particular challenge a particular
project we could hopefully choose the
tools that are going to help us hear
each other better and collaborate as a
result
and it you mentioned this glancingly but
I want to give you a chance to emphasize
this one also not only can we Aid our
imaginations by having different people
with different inclinations and skill
sets come together but narrative has the
ability to make things visceral and hit
home in a way that studies in pie charts
don't always and you have this wonderful
example of you know thinking about life
in the city where global warming has
just gone completely crazy and
everything is flooded and how much of an
impact it has on people in a way that
data and statistics just doesn't
yeah
yeah when we think about really scary
things the way that we communicate about
them most and that's obviously a result
of the fact that we live in a culture
that really prioritizes expertise
we want to present it in a way that
seems official and objective we really
prioritized and valued objectivity for a
long time let's make as rational of the
decision about what is occurring as
possible but humans we're not very
rational creatures we have a lot of
emotions when we make a decision I think
we see this when we vote for elected
officials we oftentimes vote from a very
emotional place so let's I think stop
pretending that we can aim for
objectivity as some sort of hallowed
goal because one we don't operate that
way and two pure objectivity is very
hard if not impossible to achieve we're
all coming with our embedded biases on
some level so as much as data it can be
very helpful how can we give ourselves
the opportunity to engage not just with
the practicalities of what you know new
trajectories of climatic change can be
but to really feel into them I would
love to see a world for example where
all academic institutions or think tanks
or ngos or governance organizations not
just do research and have to publish
papers
valuable for sure but also translate
that research into
experiential interventions or into some
sort of narrative form so that people
can really feel what the impacts of two
degrees Celsius versus 1.5 versus 3.5
can be like help me understand so that
hopefully we can actually use that
information to inform our non-objective
thinking like give me an emotional
response so that I can be motivated to
hopefully make a change because when
something is not connected or I don't
see how it's connected to my personal
life it's really hard for me to care
about it and again I think that's where
a system is thinking for a long time has
been kind of cordon off and you know the
purview of people who are academic
experts or you know trained
professionals
on a certain level that's totally true
but I think on a more useful level that
I would love to see system thinks
systems thinking going is for it to
basically be the context of which we
evaluate potential decisions and also
trajectories of change which means
feeling into the impacts of what a
particular decision might be to make
again the data that influences the
choices that we make or gives us an idea
of where we might be headed to make it
felt if we're talking again about
you know technological interventions 20
or 30 years in the future we're
obviously seeing with chat GPT AI is
moving at a very rapid rate
it's going to affect lots of different
things if we're going to take a systems
level perspective with this very
powerful technology
let's try and think about the impacts
that it has not just on education right
I think we've all kind of come to the
conclusion that if you can have
if you can type a phrase into chat GPT
it can give you an essay that's pretty
well written that's going to have
massive implications professors are in
panic about this it's hilarious to the
you know this is their first worry about
the AI Revolution is that it's going to
be harder to grade people's papers we're
out of a job
which is true you know some of us
definitely like won't be as necessary as
others which is also something to really
explore in detailed form what does it
mean for the future of work what does it
mean for healthcare definitely what does
it mean for decision making and the ways
that we actually come to a certain sort
of governance system that hopefully can
be Equitable over time let's look at
them in detail but not just write papers
about them and not just have discussions
like you and I are having as much as
this is a wonderful one I don't know
that it's going to help people feel into
what the implications of these
Technologies are let's really try and
make them high resolution so that we can
have hopefully a more visceral human
level on understanding about what these
Technologies could make life become
because I think that's really what it
comes down to what it's human life what
is daily life what does my life look
like in 30 years when the tools that are
already super sophisticated and the
algorithms are already so mysterious
that are shaping things like chat GPT
what do they become in 20 years and what
does that mean for my life
you've used the word phrase high
resolution a couple times and I'm pretty
sure this is obvious to everyone
listening but you're not talking about
the number of pixels on a screen you're
talking about the sort of depth of uh
detail in your scenario that you're
speculating about yeah yes yeah when we
talk about a low resolution experience
you know it might be me
saying to you hey in you know 10 years
if we're talking about AI algorithms
they're probably going to be more
sophisticated and you know they're
definitely going to be influencing the
way that I communicate with my doctor
about my Healthcare issues that's low
resolution am I giving you a kind of
General description you know things that
might occur yeah we're having an
experience talking about it or at least
you're listening to me articulate it but
it's not giving like visceral details
about what it means for you Sean a high
resolution vision is either and this can
obviously take many forms so whether
it's a virtual reality scenario of you
going to visit your doctor in 10 years
with all of the ramifications of how
machine learning will be influencing
Healthcare then or it's you reading like
a really detailed science fiction story
about maybe your child if you have
children in 10 years what their
experience of dealing with some sort of
disease that might be happening what
that might something that really
connects to what you care about to your
life whether it's you or someone that
you love and really going through an
experience of how a technology is going
to affect you and again it doesn't have
to be a technology it can be any sort of
trigger change these drivers have
changed come in many different forms
some of them are technological some of
them are social some of them are
economic right some of them are
environmental so let's look at them in
context and make them high resolution
AKA make them a detailed experience or a
narrative or role play a game that helps
you feel into what those impacts may be
so you've basically given us a toolkit
that we can use to think about these
speculative Futures so I want to bring
it back now to the cities that's where
that's where we want to make progress
here
um what what does it look like on the
ground when you sit down and say okay
let's do a urban speculative future is
this something that is a is a team
exercise or are you encouraging people
over to do it is it virtual reality
involved how does it happen it can be
any and all of those things and I will
preface this by saying that essentially
good speculative features at the present
moment in the way that they're used in
cities is essentially strong Community
engagement I think that that's
problematic in that context to really
use them in that framework but that's
the reality right the way that cities
are made now oftentimes a funder is
coming in or a bond measure has been
passed and so a certain amount of money
is allocated to our particular project
probably people have very strong ideas
about what that project is not so
dissimilar to Ridley Scott being like I
kind of know what the story is but I'm
not still going to have ask you to give
your opinion on whatever trajectory
you've changed anyways that's not so
dissimilar to what happens in cities we
kind of already know what we want to do
but we're going to ask you anyways
because we know we're supposed to
obviously there's variations in what
that actually looks like but that is a
typical way for projects to move forward
using speculative Futures in that
context can still be a way of
engendering a more robust discussion
from the people who are involved
when it's used in a more meaningful way
it's more about co-creation so ideally
people who are not experts or who are
not funders but will still be affected
by a particular project will be involved
all the way through and using
speculative Futures and these more
creative and iterative ways because
again speculative Futures are also a
fundamental part of City making you know
any architect any planner is going to
use the same tools of you know virtual
reality modeling and World building Etc
to create these narratives so when we
use them in their slightly more
provocative forms which is what some of
these sci-fi tools are which is what
some of these design fiction objects are
they're ways of broadening who is
invited to respond because not everybody
is educated to the level where like
they're going to look at a diagram
that's in a plan form and be like I
totally doubt about it because you need
a certain amount of training it's still
a design fiction on a certain level but
it's not like one that most people are
going to get excited about so specular
Futures are really ways of translating
again the fundamental process of
envisioning what does not exist and
articulating ways of making it real
which is what architecture and City
Planning is all about
and broadening the suite of levels of
expertise of kinds of people who would
feel connected to what the communication
device is of that potential future and
be able to give their responses their
preferences in return so when people are
invited to basically be collaborators on
a design project who are not experts or
Developers
speculative features can be valuable
ways about translating these ideas into
forums where a lot of people can give
their opinions and again that's where
the collaboration aspect can really be
facilitated in more meaningful ways so
these are this is why these are not
Silver Bullet tools they really depend
their success their positive impact on
how they're used and to what ends how is
a project being developed from start to
finish who are the people who are in
power and how are they basically you
know inviting more power sharing into
the process I think where speculative
Futures can also be very valuable is
that the more robust our ideas about our
preferred trajectories of change as
individuals as communities can be the
more we can advocate for what we want
and so that power sharing can be less of
something that people who have that
power decide to do and more something
that is demanded by those who will be
impacted by a potential project
it's interesting the the question of who
gets a voice in these things
um I mean you make
good points in the book about we've had
phases of what are what was called urban
renewal
with maybe the best of intentions among
certain people but then other people's
voices didn't get heard at all I can
imagine that the divisive speculative
Futures brings in lots of different
voices but I'm not sure that there's a
necessary connection there is it just
that this is one way to so what is the
connection there rather than me
speculating help me out how to how to
respect that one more time just so how
does the idea of speculative Futures as
a way of thinking about design and City
Planning
help bring in multiple voices multiple
stakeholders holders to the process
what is about
acknowledging the fact that many of us
just on a base level have limited
imagination about what can happen so you
know just to begin with let's be more
creative let's challenge our embedded
ways of thinking about what's possible
so base level when it comes to enhancing
more collaborative forms of articulating
preferred trajectories of change I think
the narrative spaces that speculative
Futures tools give us are areas where
there's Again by using that possibility
space that the future provides and
rendering the details of what that
possibility space could turn into in
terms of human impact of these potential
trajectors that we're debating The
Narrative space can be a way of giving
us a little bit of distance so that our
the impacts that they would enact on us
as individuals
maybe feel often can feel less fraught
so that we can debate more effectively
and the possibility space of this
potential future trajectory whether it's
five or ten years again change can
happen during that time so let's not get
totally embedded within the challenges
the mistrust the inequities of the
present moment and just give ourselves
that space of potential future
to again debate there's a lot of trust
that can be built if it's facilitated
that process in a thoughtful and
effective way when we build that trust
between people who are coming from
different backgrounds and sometimes it
does take a long period of time there
can be a better more effective
meaningful form of collaboration again
on preferred trajectories and once we
identify a preferred trajectory that
many different people can hopefully
agree with that's where we can start to
move back to the present moment and
identify okay if that's something that
we can agree upon what are different
ways of getting there and again there
might still be disagreement but at least
there's a commonly held vision
about where spaces could go and this
again is something that people in
different communities do all the time
but we don't necessarily have a lot of
common language common tools supported
spaces in which to do the stuff together
so these are tools again since we are
natural storytelling creatures you can
argue that the two oldest Technologies
in humanity are fire and stories stories
are what encourage us to do
and engage in Collective actions that
are quite sophisticated
we've been doing this for a long time
how can we harness that very
long-standing ancient human technique to
hopefully organize ourselves more
effectively towards the trajectories
towards which we want to go the way to
do that
in order to affect more Equitable
trajectories of changes for more of us
to be part of that together that
requires power sharing that requires
co-projection the narrative space is not
always used for that but if more of us
can collaborate on what those stories
are and again sometimes that happens via
game play sometimes that happens via
writing stories together
if we think about you know we're in the
United States very influenced by Western
European culture people argue that the
Odyssey other you know epics by Homer
they were just written by one person it
was probably a lot of different people
taking those stories and iterating on
refining them over time
speculative Futures are tools you know
we might not come up with an epic like
the Odyssey but we might come up with a
different Vision a trajectory of change
that tells us
information about where we want to go
and ideally that vision is iterated and
refined over time again I think the the
whole concept of protopia of optopia is
something that speculative Futures can
help with when it's really an iterative
process we might have something that we
agree upon at a certain scale of society
for a certain period but our
demographics change issues change
economic factors change things change so
how can that Vision be something that's
iterated upon over time so whether
speculative Futures is something that's
held by a local government and people
convene on you know a bi- yearly basis
or it's something that happens with an
organization that's kind of what we do
when we create five-year plans right
we're refining those things over time
so can we do that on a societal level
who are we what do we care about where
do we want to go
and then
translate that hopefully into action but
to do it on a repeated basis and I think
one of the challenges in the ways that
cities have been managed for so long and
you know largely today like they're so
underfunded so understaffed there's just
not a lot of resources that are there
how do we you know in gender cities to
hopefully have the resources that are
required to facilitate this kind of work
again on an ongoing basis so they can
really serve the needs of the many
different people who are living there
now and will be in years to come I think
that's very helpful for me because if I
can try to sort of rephrase the central
point from my perspective and you tell
me if I got it right or not
um of course you can do speculative
Futures as a heroic individual you don't
have to talk to anyone at all to imagine
to write a science fiction story but
maybe the point is that if you are
already committed to the idea that
different groups of people should have a
voice in Imagining the society
especially because we all have different
imaginations we all have different
interests Etc this toolkit of
speculative Futures provides a way to do
that that is especially effective
yeah I think that's a wonderful way of
saying it the things that I would add
are that this toolkit is also a way for
us to
for sure collaborate with each other but
also demand the kinds of
moves trajectories of change investment
strategies that we want because when we
have a much clearer idea about where we
would prefer to go we have the
motivation oftentimes to really try and
make those changes happen which doesn't
mean that we have to become antagonistic
with other people but it does mean that
we oftentimes have a lot more energy to
make things happen that said
we live in a bureaucratic society that
is very difficult to really harness that
energy into implementable action so
again this is not to say that if we as a
society become more facile with
speculative Futures everything will you
know suddenly change for the better just
the fact that in order to you know
figure out how to change my health care
plan takes me it feels like a week or
more in order
hindstock that is embedded in the way
our society is organized experiences
yeah but still in order to make these
potential Futures realities we do have
to be energized we have to care I when I
was 18 I spend a year working on a boat
in Polynesia doing coral reef research
and one of the islands that I spend time
at the island nation of tulalu this was
around 2004 they were already
experiencing very drastic decrees of sea
level rise and so they were very
motivated for tragic reasons to figure
out their immigration plans a lot of
them were going to move to New Zealand
other Island countries that still were
going to be safer when it came to
increasing degrees of sea level rise in
climatic change they were motivated
because climate change was deeply
personal this was around 20 years ago so
obviously things have changed since then
and more of us are feeling the impacts
of climatic change but I think that's
really to the point of when we feel
personally connected to these seemingly
abstract concepts are a very complex
systems or new technological mysterious
interventions it's hard to understand a
lot of times how they're personal so
speculative Futures their ways of making
the abstract
potential trajectories of change
personal motivating us to do something
about it and with that motivation can
come
real openings for collaborating
discussing with others and the tools are
good for feeling the personal impacts
and then also for communicating
what are preferred response trajectories
are with other people so it's kind of
the tool dual-pronged approach let me
feel first what this means for me come
up with hopefully some ideas for what I
might want to do in response and then
talk about it with other people
so after all these nice words uh
inspirational thoughts about
collaboration and bringing in different
voices I'm going to violate all of that
and close by asking you to give us your
personal vision of the perfect future
city what do you want to see
cities doing that they don't do now
wow put me on the spot here that's why
it's the end of the podcast we let our
hair down no one's you know gonna hold
you to too higher standard let your
imagination row so for me if I'm
thinking of an ideal city it's also what
I think of as a slightly more realistic
City so I'm envisioning a city
of at least 20 million people much
bigger a bigger cities yeah and so on a
governmental level I think this was a
city where people had space for
imaginative co-creation to occur on an
ongoing basis again this is something
that's kind of like jury duty we're just
doing it because we live in this place
together we are using these speculative
Futures tools to translate Visions
action steps identified through these
co-creation processes into planning
initiatives policy recommendations
infrastructural interventions so that
the city at this quite large level is
able to iterate between strategic
implementation opportunities with the
visions that are co-created on an
ongoing basis I think of NGO Civil
Society acting as mediators maybe in
some of these processes mostly by taking
the research that they develop and
translating them into experiential
narrative speculative forms that people
can engage with so there's a certain
level of legibility that our society has
that is not dependent on people getting
a PhD or some degree it's just because
they're translated in forms that more of
us understand I.E narratives I.E some of
these speculative features forums I
think of the business and the private
sector focusing on funding you know
literacy in these different sorts of
interventions what if you know a very
wealthy and problematic company like
meta is really funding Civic engagement
with complex
research-based initiatives that are just
in Civic public space so it's not about
even having a headset or a particular
kind of technological tool but they're
projected in some sort of publicly
available way for all people to engage
with in order to learn about some of the
issues that are facing their particular
area over time
and as individuals I think about us
hopefully becoming more engaged with
exploring the role of future
trajectories of change in our own lives
what does that look like as both an
individual practice and maybe also as a
relational practice how do people talk
if they have kids with what their lives
might be like in 20 30 years kids are
amazing and just imagining whole
alternative trajectories how can we
really invite people who are younger to
be a part of these conversations again
not in ways where we're talking down to
them but really
appreciated that like their advantage of
capacity is that a whole other level how
can we support those imaginative
capacities to really be embedded not
just in these larger visioning processes
but also on an individual level how
we're thinking about these trajectories
change so I have lots of ideas also on
the infrastructural interventions and
the different sorts of ways that
technological tools could improve these
future cities and not that I don't think
that those are important to voice but I
think what's much more important to the
way so we spend a lot less time focused
on is how we come to these decisions
together and I think that that
particular process of different scales
of society different sectors of society
being engaged in this work of
envisioning alternative trajectories of
change that they would prefer is
essential to creating the more Equitable
spaces the infrastructural interventions
the way that we are embracing different
technological tools essential but what
is
even more essential is how we have those
discussions together
you've given us a lot to think about
most of which is how very very
complicated this whole topic is I I
presume that you yourself think that
this is something you'll never
completely wrap your head around all the
different aspects of what goes into this
this is uh you know the maybe I don't
know whether Neuroscience or City
Planning is the is the better example of
something where there's just so much
complexity that we nibble at the edges
and it can seem very intimidating to us
for sure and also as much as it is
complex and I'm never going to fully
understand it nor really think any other
individual I do think it's also quite
fun oh yeah and I think that is an
undervalued attribute like it's
fascinating and it can also be really
yeah exciting and fun and I think that
that's a valuable thing that speculative
teachers tools provide which arguably
City making needs more of let's make it
fun so we actually want to do it with
each other exciting and fun and
important so Joanna Hoffman thanks very
much for being on the mindscape podcast
thanks Sean it was such a pleasure
[Music]
la la la la